hello everyone welcome back to the
Capablanca saga we are at the final
round of the 1911 Thunder Bastian
tournament where Jose raúl capablanca
faces slovenian mechanical engineer dr.
Milan Widmar a very strong grandmaster
also one of the strongest players in the
world at that time not only at that time
he was considered to be one in the top
ten somewhere between 1910 and 1930 but
before we get to the game I do have a
couple of short announcements for those
of you who have enjoyed best of our
matters funny moments created by Les Mis
yes you'll be very happy to know that he
has created a video part 2 so if you
want in the description below it will be
a link to the video that is on his
channel so feel free to check it out
it's he put a lot of work into it so
feel free to enjoy it and also I would
like to mention yesterday while watching
a movie with Jelena I challenged Team
YouTube to a game of chess as you can
see I was very impressed how much time
they are spending on Twitter helping
people you know with their YouTube
problems and I told them since you're so
active lately 1.e4 and they replied they
said e v as you can see I said to f4 I
decided to go for the for the Kings
gambit and well the game continued but
we only play that maybe ten ten or so
moves I believe nine but we're still
deciding on which move they played and
the knight moves but we'll get back to
that after we show you the game quite
quite an interesting moment and also I
did prepare something for you here like
I said this is the final round last game
we've seen his capablanca against the
Akiba Rubinstein work up a blank who
lost the game but one thing you didn't
know is that for the last four games of
this tournament which is the 1911
tournament of San Sebastiano Capablanca
had a fever so he complained he already
started complaining about it during his
game with the rule of Spielman then it
got worse during his game with a
keyboard and then with during his game
with pikemen as you can see here they
only played eight moves this is the
penultimate round the game before this
one and it says a draw was agreed upon
after eight moves but the chief arbiter
shot misses
says that well the the scoresheet was
tampered with and that more than eight
moves were played but up to this day the
the real moves were not recovered so for
as far as we know it could just be again
we're eight moves were played like you
see here that was published in an
article in 1911 but also now I I will
put a link to this article also in the
description it's an article by Edward
winter but also it could be like the
greatest game ever played that ended in
a draw and we will never know Albert
okay it's not not hard to imagine that
capablanca would play an eight move draw
if he already had a fever for three days
in a row and I didn't want to mention it
during the game with a keeper of instant
it would diminish Rubenstein's the
victory and it really was a brilliant
say against kappa blanka so i mean it's
not his fault
if capablanca maybe played sub-optimally
because he really punished the
punishment Blanc like a true master of
the game and here kappa blanka mentions
that he really woke up with a with a
terrible fever
he asked dr. melon Widmar if he would be
interested in taking the game to another
room where it was less crowded where
there was less smoke and did okay dr.
Mullen did not agree that they took the
game into a different room couple Wonka
says that there were a lot of windows in
the room but all of the windows windows
were closed and it was really hot in
there and a couple uncle with his fever
simply couldn't handle it so I during
the game Capablanca started first he
opened one window then he opened another
window then another and another and by
the games and all the windows were open
as the story goes yeah if it's true or
not I have no idea but okay yeah the the
point is it's a very interesting game
because it's a final game of this great
tournament the 1911 tournament or San
Sebastian and the dr. Mullen Whitmer has
a chance to win to win this tournament
capablanca has a chance to win this
tournament and also a key barometer has
a chance to win this tournament but
luckily for capablanca and dr. Mullen
Whitmer Rubinstein drew his last game
against the rule of Shaolin
so
Robinson is fortunately for the two of
them out of the game and dr. villain
mill and Widmer is the like a couple
ANCA has only lost one game so far
cover Blanca lost to Rubenstein you
already seen that game and dr. Mullen
Widmer lost Frank James Marshall
it was really an impressive game by
Marshall with the white pieces as
Marshall played in the positional style
which is not really like him but really
a brilliancy a 30 move brilliancy so
everyone has a chance okay I may be
spoiled a little bit because I said
Rubinstein drew his game but as we will
not be showing it maybe we'll be showing
it during the Rubinstein saga but then I
will check again who remembers what I
said
swim also I found this very nice photo
of for several blankets all from the
1911 sensible tournament so there you
have it we can just enjoy it
it's not the greatest foe robot I mean
it's 1911 we can't really complain Sam
and now let's check out the game Emil on
vidmark has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 and it was actually in
1911 that dr. Miller and Widmer got his
doctor's degree in the technical Faculty
of Vienna so a great year for him one
could say we have d4 d5 c4
sorry about that we have e six the
Queens gambit declined is on the board
Knight to c3 and now c5 Capablanca goes
for the tower defense yet again we have
III sorry III Knight to f6 Knight to f3
and the Knights the c6 so this is the
symmetrical variation very nicely placed
all of the pieces and pawns of the tower
defense Bishop to d3 and only now that
the bishop has been developed Capablanca
will capture and c4 forcing the white
bishop to lose the tempo Bishop captures
and now Bishop to e7 Capablanca prepares
the castle
we have castles capablanca also castles
and now D captures on c5 it's a weird
move taking from the center but there's
no good better developing more for white
you can't improve any the position of
any of your pieces you don't want to
play a move like Bishop to d2
and I mean you can't really develop the
Queen the Queen will be somewhat
misplaced on see - you don't want to
play Queen b3 because the knight could
create a double attack against the
bishop and the Queen so this is actually
a developed development developmental
move is if it said like that yeah
and now offering a queen trait if Queen
captures rook will capture bringing the
rook over to the D file so we have Queen
captures capablanca decides to trade
Queens we have rookie actress on d1 and
now Bishop captures on c5 recapturing
the pawn so here meal and dinner has an
excellent opportunity he has a great
position against not a great position
but not another worst position against
capablanca in the final round with the
white pieces if he wins he wins the 1911
tournament of San Sebastiano it's okay
and I don't know if Widmar knew that
Capablanca was suffering with fever but
if capablanca asked you know if it could
be if the game could be transferred to
another room then surely he had some
ideas it's okay we have a three
preparing B for cup of Blanco goes b6
that prepares to fianchetto the light
square bishop we have before now Bishop
goes back to e7 and now comes he for
Widmore's idea is to push this pawn all
the way to e5 and to grab control of the
d6 square he also wants to play Bishop
to f4 to gain further control of the d6
square and then play Knight b5 and
create an outpost for this night on d6
so quite quite a plan for white we'll
see how it goes
a couple uncle goes roof to d8 he
counters with Mars rook on d1 we have
Bishop to f4 and now comes Bishop to b7
Capablanca simply develops and the
vidmark continues with his plan he 5
grabbing more control of the d6 square
and now the idea is night b-52d 6 we
have night Stewie 8 going back and also
keeping further control of the d6 square
Bishop back to d3 and now comes Luke a
to c8 and now nights to b5 everything is
now in order
the knight is ready to jump here also da
seven points pressured and here we have
looked the d5 by kappa blanka if
Capablanca
to play something like a 6 to try and
get rid of this night then 9 thesis is
actually a very strong move your your
you can't capture it you have to leave
it there but also you can't leave it
there so after something like Bishop
captures each captures you will not be
able to keep on recapturing because
after real captures you will suffer an
exchange here and a pawn after a bedroom
captures because your rook on d6 is
undefended Robert okay after Knight b5
we have looked the d5 Capablanca sets a
trap and well a V damar it's not really
a trap but it really diminishes White's
chances to look for anything in the
endgame the vidmar goes for the same
idea vidmar plays Knight to d6 and now
capablanca captures with Knight captures
pawn captures and Bishop captures so why
is this different why wonder what was
coupled longus plant here vide mark
captures on d6 and now of course you
cannot recapture because of the same
idea Bishop captures and h7 but what
capablanca can do and it's also a very
nice moment for you to pause the game
find the finders the next move for black
as it's the only move for black that
doesn't lose for those of you who are
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent finder of copper Blancas ideas
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy show the most rook to d8 now
everything is in order and it was
actually in this position unmoved 20
that josé raúl capablanca
and dr. Mullen Vidmar agreed to a draw
seems a bit funny because Vidmar needs a
win against Capablanca to get first
place in this tournament but also if he
doesn't agree to a draw here we would
probably see the following either Bishop
to c7 getting the bishop out of the way
attacking the roof now comes the bishop
rook here and now white is down upon so
white has to give up either this bishop
or this bishop and white would have to
grab upon eventually even material now
let's say Bishop captures now we get
rook capture son d3 rook captures rook
captures and now this bishop would move
here as the opponent a7 is guarded by
the night and we would reach this
position where the material is equal we
have bishops of opposite color and well
black is a
a bit more active so you're not really
gonna find any chances against kappa
blanka and game like this or another
possibility after roof to d8 would be
something like grabbing on h7
immediately like a bunch of captures and
then after team captures rook captures
here pawn captures and after Bishop to
f4 now again the material is equal but
now black has a very strong past deep on
which he can push and well you're not
going to be getting that much chances
against capablanca in this position
either so here dr. Nealon Widmer had a
very unique choice will he draw against
capablanca in this position either
equally or slightly worse or will he
pursue this game and try to push for
something more than a draw because he
knows capablanca has a fever so you know
even though cover Lanka is such a great
endgame player and everything perhaps he
could you know be a sneaky player and
try to try to turn this around but he
doesn't he agrees for a draw here and
this means that by this draw I do have
the final standings of the 1911 census
Bastion tournament here horrible
Capablanca wins the tournament with nine
and a half out of 14 and that's what six
wins one loss that the one against the
keeper who entertained that we've seen
and seven drawers and also we have dr.
Malone read more after drawing this game
would Capablanca he ties with Akiba
ravine Stein with nine out of 14 with
five wins one loss that one against
Frank Frank James Marshall and eight
draws and the only player that went
undefeated in this tournament and has
defeated the winner of the tournament is
Akiba Rubinstein the Polish prodigy
Polish grandmaster with four wins 0
losses but 10 draws so if if anything
well ok now that we know a couple Lanka
you know we're suffering with fever for
the last four games we can bring a
little sympathy into it but that does
not diminish Rubenstein's achievement in
this tournament our buddy dr. Miller and
Widmer
decided to draw this not to put for
anything and you know at least tie for
second and third place with a key
barometer
and grab some of that first to third
place money assume that was the 1911
tournament of San Sebastiano poblanos
first international tournament I do hope
you enjoyed it couple Blanca sure did as
if you have been following the
Capablanca saga from the beginning we've
said something about couple Uncas
childhood then how he developed up until
he was 12 to 13 years old we mentioned
his match against one core so the
champion of Cuba then we also covered
that how he didn't know it in any
openings at that time then we went to
his match with Frank James Marshall who
he just obliterated it was just in
saying how good coupled one could played
that match without all that many you
know opening theory knowledge and then
even though he did not have he did not
qualify to play in this tournament of
San Sebastian it was actually Frank
James Marshall who helped him get get an
entry to this tournament and Indian josé
raúl capablanca won this tournament
similarly how how Fisher didn't have
Houser didn't qualify for the palma de
mallorca tournament because he didn't
play the the United States Championship
but then you know everything just worked
in his favor and he he came to play and
then he wanted but iam definitely and an
impressive showing by josé raúl
capablanca
and now we will go forward with our
capablanca saga we are going into
negotiations with Emmanuel Lasker
because now after a cup of Monica's
great showing in this tournament he now
feels confident and will challenge dr.
Emmanuel Alaska for the title but it's
it's not as simple as it seems the
negotiations will be quite vast so I
will even consider making a separate
video just for the negotiations to keep
it separate from the games but I will
only consider it I haven't decided yet
Sam yeah we're gonna do that then we're
gonna perhaps check up on some more
tournaments that capablanca played
before facing Alaska and yeah we're
gonna see how it goes I haven't really
decided the entire path of the capo
Blanca saga so I will just wing it
yeah yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you have been
enjoying the Capablanca saga so far
like I mentioned do checkout best best
moments best funny moment so this
channel made by Les Mis yes the link
will be in the description below to
check up on some other links and like I
said if you are if you're on Twitter or
would like to join Twitter to follow
this game between me and Team YouTube
it's it's a Kings gambit we're playing a
wild variation you know no cheating no
one is using engines of course it's hard
to believe this because you can never
know if the other person is choosing to
be aided by an engine but there is this
thing called the honor so you know that
still exists I don't really care if I
lose or win this game against the team
YouTube because in the end it's always
chess that wins and I'm really hoping to
make it an interesting game that's why I
chose the Kings gambit and hoping to
really make it interesting and it's I
mean team YouTube is playing should be a
very nice promotion for this game of
chess that we enjoy so much yeah if you
would like to join in I will put a link
to this my original tweet in the
description below feel free to retweet
it so more people will follow follow
this match and you know you can also
help out in promoting chess but don't
post any engine lines don't post any you
can post like move suggestions or or
comment on the game but don't use an
engine it will just ruin the fun for
everyone so yeah like I said that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Tyler Davis dieter Patrick
Paul staples Hawking dr. Liddle and
Marcia London for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content maybe even with a Twitter
immortal game but we'll see how it goes
thank you all and have an excellent rest
of your day